So the process for actually getting
an investment varies depending on
who you're taking the money from.
So for example,
in places like an accelerator like
in effect it's very structured.
There is a date in which have
to submit your application.
The application there
includes many questions.
We then review the application.
We invite part of the companies for
interviews.
They come for interviews,
we decide who it is.
We have a date in which we announce
to them that they're in, so
that's very structured and very easy.
Which is a big benefit for
the company, because they know when
it starts, they know when it ends.
When you look at angel investors or
early stage funders,
it's very different.
The reason is that the angel investor or
the funder not have any risk constraints
on when do they need to invest.
And as the early stage investor,
theoretically the best thing for
you is to delay a little bit and
see what's going to happen next,
and what's going to happen next.
And sure if you're about
to launch something,
I'll be stupid to not wait and
see how does that go right?
Because I'm going to give you money.
Now that's not true of course, why?
Because as an investor if
you're delaying the company,
you're basically setting yourself up for
failure because as we said,
speed is the most important thing.
However, the outcome of this is that
the processes are very unstructured.
And I can tell you that
there were companies where,
at the end of a one hour meeting,
I told them I'm in.
And then we worked on the documents for
another few days and I invested.
And I can tell you there were companies
that took me half a year to invest.
Because it took me half year to cross
the chasm of believing in the team.
That the team is strong enough where
there's something that we call
here's product market fit
that everybody knows, but
there's also what's called a founder
product fit or a founder market fit.
And so, many times it takes me a period
of time to get to know the founders,
to believe that they're the right
people to win this domain.
And many times they're great people but
they're just not the right people for
this domain.
So it's everything from one hour
to six months and it is for
the entrepreneur to manage the process.
That's one of the things that
entrepreneur are missing in most times,
in most cases.
And when I said to manage the process
clearly part of it is creating this
vector of movement of investors that
are starting to invest in your company.
Because investors at the end
of the day they're people and
as people, well most of them are people,
and as people there is the herd effect.
And when you hear that other
people started committing
it makes your life a lot easier.
And so as investor, you need to sort of
plan to have everything culminates to
people starting to invest and
then going gone and everybody investing.
That does include planning side
which we know that was possible.
But when I say managing the process,
the meaning is that you do not need,
you can't let the ball drop.
And if you expect the investor to
be the one leading the process
then you're wrong because the investor
has 50 like you, that are all waiting.
And it's going to be the ones
that are driving the process
that are going to be
getting more attention.
And so I'm not and there is
the thin line between nagging and
overdoing it and
running the process properly.
But if you're just sitting in there
waiting for the email to come back and
waiting for
somebody to set up the meeting and
not being proactive,
you're losing on two form.
The first thing is that somebody
else is doing to consider getting
less attention.
The second thing,
your ability to present the right
character to the investor goes away.
And so be proactive, manage the process.
And know that by basically
getting many investors
to get to the decision point at the same
time you're dramatically increasing your
chance of raising the money you want.